[Música]
en el salvador las mujeres que sufren de
complicaciones durante la gestión la
gestación y que dan lugar a abortos
espontáneos son habitualmente
sospechosas de haberse practicado una
interrupción del embarazo las señaladas
son procesadas bajo el cargo de
homicidio agravado cuya pena de cárcel
es de 30 años con la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo prohibida en
todos los casos incluidos los generados
en circunstancias de violación incesto
cuando la vida de la gestante está en
peligro en los últimos 20 años las
autoridades salvadoreñas procesaron
penalmente a unas 181 mujeres que
sufrieron emergencias estéticas esta
semana una de ellas fue liberada tras
pasar 10 años en prisión para ello
entonces quiero abordar el tema con
nuestra primera invitada y es carmen
cecilia martínez directora asociada de
estrategias legales para américa latina
y el caribe del centro de derechos
reproductivos gracias a por estar con
nosotros carmen en directo américa de
france 24 le preguntó entonces qué tan
grave es la situación en el salvador en
torno a este tema
muchísimas gracias buenos días buenos
días a toda la audiencia bueno para
responder la pregunta la situación en el
salvador es realmente grave digamos que
a partir del año 98 cuando se revirtió
la ley que permitía el servicio de salud
de interrupción del embarazo en ciertas
excepciones
pasó a ser que
ya pasó a ser una ley de esta mente
restrictiva
sean por lo menos identificado por parte
de la agrupación ciudadana en el
salvador al menos más de 180 casos de
mujeres que por sufrir o enfrentar
emergencias obstétricas en condiciones
precarias de salud
son criminalizadas por la supuesta
sospecha del delito de aborto cuando
efectivamente no han cometido ningún
delito y se les condena entre 30 y 50
años de prisión justamente una de esas
mujeres fue el xi que afortunadamente
pudo lograr su libertad el día de ayer
atrás estar tras las rejas por casi 10
años y dejando a su hijo fuera de la
cárcel en que se basan carmen las
autoridades para determinar que una
persona realmente practicó un aborto fue
un aborto espontáneo cuál es la
investigación que hacen las autoridades
en este caso del salvador para procesar
a una mujer realmente se respeta toda
esta investigación no solamente usted
como le estaba diciendo simplemente
sospechosa y ya tiene la pena
esta es una pregunta muy importante
porque lo que pasa en el salvador no
solamente es que ahí vemos los de los
debata los devastadores efectos de una
ley completamente restrictiva sino que
además digamos todo esto opera a partir
de estereotipos de género que que se
traducen en que la mujer por su
capacidad reproductiva o su capacidad de
gestar debe asumir unos costos y iii y
iv y sobreponerse frente a cualquier
emergencia obstétrica que está
enfrentando incluso cuando están
desmayadas convalecientes por ese
supuesto instinto maternal que debe
existir no este es a partir de este
estereotipo de género que no solamente
opera un sistema de justicia que
incumple todas las garantías del debido
proceso sino que también es empleado por
el personal por gran parte del personal
de salud que actúa a modo de escritorio
de institución de perseguir la ley o
perseguir el delito a modo de policía y
presume que se hacen un aborto en lugar
de
atender las emergencias en salud que las
mujeres están enfrentando y activan
efectivamente el sistema penal entonces
todo esto en el salvador digamos si bien
el principio que debe primar siempre es
el principio digno de presunción de
inocencia de inocencia en el salvador lo
que opera es justamente lo contrario en
un principio de culpas de presunción de
culpabilidad a partir de estereotipos
descarados de géneros desde que las
mujeres intentan buscar atención
obstétrica de emergencia esto no sabía
entonces hablar de los derechos
reproductivos de la mujer tanto en el
salvador como en américa latina donde
queda la decisión de la mujer sobre su
cuerpo
sino absolutamente digamos que el
panorama en américa latina tiene avances
y también retrocesos no tiene avances
como los podemos ver en argentina pues
en chile justamente un avance preliminar
hacia los hacia la garantía de los
derechos fundamentales que son los
derechos reproductivos también y son
además servicios esenciales de salud que
deben ser garantizados como tal dicho
por incluso por la organización mundial
de la salud y respecto del salvador
honduras por ejemplo nicaragua seguimos
viendo leyes absolutamente restrictiva
que ponen en riesgo además la vida la
salud los proyectos de vida de niñas y
mujeres en estos países e incluso a las
víctimas de violación que enfrentan
entonces embarazos y maternidad
esforzados algo muy importante es que
por lo menos en el salvador y en la
región estos casos similares al de él sí
a partir de la sentencia de la corte
interamericana
que justamente se emitió en diciembre
del año pasado en el caso de manuela
contra el salvador ninguna mujer debería
ser nunca más
denunciada ante las autoridades penales
por enfrentar servicios por infectar una
emergencia obstétrica o buscar servicios
de salud reproductiva en un hospital
manuel era una mujer que como elx y
muchas otras al menos 180 más mujeres
fue criminalizada por enfrentar una
emergencia obstétrica de salvador cuando
además se enfrentaba a un cáncer de
linfoma de hodgkin es muy importante
conocer esta sentencia y que a partir de
ello ni las autoridades deberían ejercer
todos este de todos estos estereotipos
que operan en el caso y las autoridades
de salud deben remitirse solamente a la
esfera de la salud que les corresponde
ahora actualmente 11 mujeres se
encuentran en prisión condenadas por
visiones de salvador como al cometer
supuestamente un aborto le pregunto cuál
es la situación legal de estas mujeres
cuál va a ser el futuro
pues realmente digamos junto con las
organizaciones locales y otros organista
u otras organizaciones internacionales
realmente esperamos que estas mujeres
puedan ser liberadas lo más pronto
posible estas 11 mujeres cumplen no
solamente son inocentes pero además
cumplen con los requisitos para que
puedan obtener beneficios penitenciarios
y finalmente poder estar con sus
familias digamos que el salvador las
tiene retenidas y detenidas y condena
detenidas de manera arbitraria con
condenas que violaron todas las
garantías y protecciones judiciales por
lo cual merecen en seguida su libertad y
otro paso a seguir que esperamos también
es que pues justamente como él si en
ella sale de prisión gracias a un
beneficio penitenciario y además por la
lucha de las organizaciones pero
esperamos que el gobierno pueda reparar
a él sí y a todas estas mujeres que han
pesar que han pasado décadas de su vida
en prisión por un delito que nunca
cometieron sino que enfrentaron
procesos naturales de sus embarazos dado
su capacidad de gestar simplemente
fueron criminalizadas por con base en
estos estereotipos que operaron a lo
largo de toda fuente de toda su atención
desde que intentaron acceder a la
institucionalidad ahora el presidente
salvadoreño nadie buque le afirmó que
dejará por fuera una propuesta de la
constitución que modifique cualquier ley
a favor de la despenalización del aborto
también entre personas igualitarias
digamos hablando de estos temas un poco
progresivos para como lo llaman los
conservadores porque un presidente que
se mostraba como un cambio se hacía
llamar también un millennial en nuestro
resisten estos temas porque tiene esta
política de años atrás en su país esto
no va a cambiar eso todo esto va a
seguir en el sábado las mujeres van a
seguir siendo condenadas y
estigmatizadas por todo por todas estas
leyes salvadoreñas
si desafortunadamente esta es una
tendencia que estamos viendo no
solamente en el salvador sino también en
honduras donde justamente el a
principios del año pasado hubo una
reforma constitucional absolutamente
viciada en donde justamente se pretendió
pues se incluyó al final una cláusula
digamos pétrea que prohíbe el acceso a
la interrupción del embarazo y además al
a la unión marital de parejas del mismo
sexo o por supuesto tanto el salva de
tanto el salvador como honduras más allá
de que diga el poder de lo que diga el
poder ejecutivo está incumpliendo con
sus obligaciones internacionales en este
tema con la diferencia que el salvador
gracias a la sentencia de manuela en el
caso por parte de la corte
interamericana tiene la obligación de no
continuar con esta práctica sistemática
y estructural que persigue a mujeres que
efectivamente todas se encuentran en
situación de pobreza han tenido acceso a
muy poca escolaridad y enfrentan de
nuevo estas emergencias por situaciones
muy precarias